I want you to hear the truth from me as
much as I can share not as a prince or
joke but as hairy it was in front of
friends that Prince Harry broke his
silence at a private dinner for his
charity center Bali he explained why he
and Megan had to step down from their
royal roles we both do everything we can
to fly the flag and carried out our
roles for this country with pride
once Megan and I were married we were
incited we were hopeful and we were here
to serve for those reasons it brings me
great sadness that it has come to this
the decision that I have made for my
wife and I to step back is not one I
made lightly
there was so many months of talks after
so many years of challenges and I know I
haven't always done it right but as far
as this goes there really was no other
option describing how they had wanted to
continue their royal work but also how
the media had pushed them away what I
want to make clear is we're not walking
away and we certainly aren't walking
away from you our hope was to continue
serving the Queen the Commonwealth and
my military associations but without
public funding unfortunately that wasn't
possible the media is a powerful force
and my hope is one day our collective
support for each other can be more
powerful because this is so much bigger
than just us
his speech came just 24 hours after
queen who was seen going to church in
Norfolk on Sunday had given her blessing
to a deal that would allow Harry and
Megan to have this new independent life
no press were invited for his speech
instead it was filmed for the couple's
Instagram account very different to what
his mother faced in 1993 when she
announced she was stepping down but his
reasons for going are strikingly similar
I understood the media might be
interested in what I did but I was not
aware of how overwhelming that attention
would become when they got engaged this
was a couple excited about what they
could achieve together it hasn't been
the fairy tale we'd all built it up to
be and in this next chapter there was no
chance of being part time Royals a
sacrifice that Harry has sadly had to
make for his dream of a peaceful new
family life Rhiannon Mills Sky News at
Buckingham Palace